a portion of Highway in Philadelphia
collapsed Sunday morning after a large
vehicle fire investigators theorized a
fuel tanker is the source of the fire
that destabilized and brought down an
entire portion of the Northbound Lanes
of Interstate 95. the southbound side of
the interstate has also been compromised
due to the blaze Flames could be seen
shooting up from the roadway and thick
black smoke filled the sky as traffic
was stopped in the area we did have a
collapse of 95 okay on the excuse me on
the Northbound side okay and the
southbound side is compromised by heavy
fire looked like we had a lot of heat
and heavy fire underneath the underpass
okay
no reporting of any occupants or or or
or drivers or anything like that we
don't have any of that yet but as you
see we have all of our team here to uh
you know we'll be here for a while what
you hear Let me let me explain the
explosions you hear those are the runoff
of uh maybe some fuel or gas lines that
could have been compromised by the
accident okay so that's what you hear in
the uh I guess is the release of the uh
of that we have fire coming out of those
manholes so we'll be here you know until
this is over
um because the complexity is the state
uh roadway behind us there's obviously
uh being close to the Delaware River
with the storm drains involved we're
concerned about the environmental
impacts as well what the runoff might
look like and so um yes it's a it's a
response from all the above and what you
see is just one layer of kind of that
response right now what's going on
behind the scenes is of course we have
PennDOT and Pennsylvania State Police
engaged for the state infrastructure
State roadway but then of course U.S
Coast Guard monitoring as well with City
Hazmat forces for the environmental side
of it this is going to be today's going
to be a long day and obviously with with
95 Northbound gone uh you know in
southbound questionable it's going to be
even longer than that so
this is all very preliminary right now
we really just kind of want to tell you
guys what the next couple hours look
like and what it looks is getting all
those agencies involved whether they're
headquartered here in Philadelphia
Harrisburg or Beyond engage on the same
page and make sure we understand what
needs to happen the recovery alone is
going to be I mean it's heavy
construction equipment going to be
required to come in and start to remove
that debris
a little happy I mean it would happen